um the big stuff for me obviously was
was wolverine to see wolverine um i just
my thing is how many people are working
at insomniac because insomniac has to
have 500 i mean is that the point can we
we can make the argument now right they
are okay they're the number one i mean
we know nobody dog as far as the quality
but you could still say that right but
naughty dog is going to give you the two
games of generation who did the trailer
for
for wolverine
i'm assuming it's insane yeah he's a
zombie oh they farmed it out to somebody
to be put together they farmed it out
give me a cgi trailer for this game that
we're going to do later
they don't need a billion devs i mean a
billion workers to put up oh no i'm just
saying
they're making their game they're making
spider-man they're working hard they're
putting sony on their back it is
fantastic i think people are
y'all caught up in the moment
nah dude
bro
these guys have been working since god
god bless you this is
ratchet and clank 2016. god bless
god bless you they dropped spiderman
right drop miles morales right they drop
ripped apart they deserve to be
purchased
there
and remember what they purchased them
for 200 million dollars like a
ridiculously low amount of money
whatever their workflow is it is the
most efficient workflow in gaming right
100
in addition to that that studio is
bigger than we think it is
there's no way there's no way they're
all just working on this one game and
then jump to the next you drop
spider-man and then you drop dlc
ratchet and clank whatever the case is
the formula is still the same
the graphics all right put this little
thing here but this is wait so what's
the point you're trying to make
i was just getting to after you finish
i'm gonna give you my predict my show
okay what what i saw with the show so
are you saying that they don't deserve
necessarily the prophecy no they are
they are right now they are holding sony
on their back i'm not disputing 100
percent oh yeah
everybody said they're getting up at the
moment we're not allowed to be hyper all
right no no no no no i'm not saying that
i'm not saying that
um you don't get a chance to eat a
terrible meal
and then be happy for the dessert
all right
that's all i'm talking about
but you don't know how happy i am about
the meal
the conversations
came from what they showed right
so
so okay obviously wolverine i'm excited
for whenever that comes out gran turismo
i'm kind of with 3mg that like for me
gran turismo has not been the same for a
long time i you know and for me forza
has taken that spot i'm not even a big
sim guy like that so when i think about
a racing game i'm thinking about horizon
i'm thinking about other things um
gran turismo looks beautiful
we'll see if it does come out in march
like they say it's gonna come out we
will see or whenever it's supposed to
come out um spider-man 2 look great
obviously anybody who played the first
one knows the whole venom stuff uh and
cravings to hear craving the hunter is
exciting
um
god of war
so god of war
and this is a my bad type of thing is
i guess i expected more
for whatever reason
everything that i saw i'm like yes more
god of war great
four years on hey
i
when i finished the game in 2018 i'm
like okay
i love more god of war right now
four years removed i'm like more god of
war in kind of exactly the same vein it
was a little underwhelming i'm gonna
play it i think it's gonna be a super i
think it's gonna be a huge game because
there isn't gonna be a trilogy this is
the end of the whole norse sort of
timeline
so they're going to egypt next like this
is like he announced that i'm thinking
this is going to be okay
yeah he said like this we're going to
end the story here of like norse like of
the norse mythology so
to me that means this is a last of us
two size game
um in terms of you know 30 35 hours
worth of gameplay
i'm excited for it
god award a lot of ways was was amazing
i love the combat everything about it it
was again it was i think my expectations
were different than what i saw right it
still looked great it was so polished
but i wasn't wow i was weirdly on i was
surprised that i was under well okay
yeah all right so i give them this i
give them six and a half to seven oh wow
okay yeah all right no doubt king you've
been waiting patient let's get to it
score the whole bit
well yeah they got a five um
jesus they got a five i'm keeping the
same energy with those cgi stuff else
stuff i'm keeping the same energy with
the cgi stuff all right
so um all right i want to add something
real quick to your statements kane do
you think like you know bring this up
sometime in what you're saying do you
think that maybe sony's getting a little
comfortable with the milk shake and
fries like because they are showing a
lot of exclusives on you know sequels
i know chicken fries how to do about
releasing the same games over and over
well no they they're kind of doing that
now
okay they're in sql city they are in
there
he already told jim dansman ryan's
already said that he's going to double
down on the triple a titles the big
titles um so that's no surprise none of
this stuff is a surprise them opening up
the show with a bunch of multi-plats in
the beginning and the chessboard game
trailer i sat there and you are not
supposed to on yo on your d-day
you're not supposed to have me running
around in my room laughing at you do not
and don't ever forget it go back and
watch it i laughed at you for 45 minutes
and you showed up for the last 10
minutes and was like shut up king you
don't get to say shut up king you don't
get to say shut up king for something i
said they better have this here to save
the show
they show god of war
then they showed cgi trailer
cgi trailer
and here we go king we good
no we're not good we are not good
now god of war i was happy with what i
saw
because i knew that dlc was coming at
some point in time
and i knew it was going to look the same
exact way that it did i see people all
upset it don't look next-gen king it
don't look
it's on the same engine this is peaceful
using the same assets
if you think the turnaround was going to
be uh how how long did you stop acting
like you don't know how long games take
to make
so yes i'm very happy for a new god of
war
i'm more happy for spider-man but i had
to take off points because of the cgi
trailer
that's the only thing i only took away
points for the cgi stuff and i say the
same thing with microsoft you come with
that cgi stuff i'm going to get you you
do you say this i'm a good guy okay i
didn't know that you could save energy
with that yeah i don't care for that
yeah
show me something that's not
representative of what i'm going to get
don't do that for me don't don't don't
show me something and then debate and
switch later on oh and then they go back
and sort of downgrade been down that
road already
all right so
we're gonna keep the same energy when
microsoft showed a bunch of multiplex
everybody was like oh my god what are
they doing that's over there that's over
there that's over there okay
none of that stuff interests me when i
watch a sony show i watch with my money
my wallet what i'm going to buy
gran turismo looks very tempting
it does and if it does come out before
forza the next motorsports game i think
i might be buying gran turismo
to just get my sim game in right it
looks that good don't don't don't please
don't front like it don't look that good
it dude
god of war i'm gonna buy it spider-man
i'm gonna buy it damn you know look at
my room i'm gonna get wolverine when it
come out
so at no point that's an eight right
there right but then i have to minus out
for them cgi's one point for each of
those so that brings it down to a five
because none of those multipliers i'm
buying from them that's hot i'm not
doing it fair enough all right so if
you're telling me to spend 70 80 on your
games it got to be something i'm going
to open my wallet for the games that i'm
opening my wallet for you held it for
the last 10 minutes of the show addicts
said it perfectly if somebody's watching
this show
they left early on and heard about the
announcements later
so it didn't hit if you had a fly in
your soup at your restaurant you're
sending it back to the kitchen and
you're out of there i'm not paying for
this it's a roach in my food
if that's for me for free i might eat it
depending on my finances
we've all been there three years we've
all been there
but anyway it's just listen
i see people they happy sony did
something at the end of the show because
if they would have just showed that god
of war and walked out the door
i would have been upset
and walked out the door these dudes
these dudes are so sick i do feel like
without man i do feel like
i do feel like without wolverine we
wouldn't be having this conversation
but that's all i'm saying is just people
are acting like they didn't see the same
thing i saw and i and i'm not saying
that those multi-plats don't look good
i'm not saying that
but when we go into a sony show right
when microsoft do it oh they got
multiplex why are they showing
multiplats why are they doing why y'all
showing multiplex actually like that oh
you see you see
see i'm starting to understand you more
you see
you've allowed
that side
to get to you so that's why
well you're not wrong because
look listen you remind me a lot like
chase once we see a trail in this cgi it
ain't gonna look like that though
that's what it do that's what you do
there's a point to be made here i'm on
that same type of time my excitement
wasn't just but you know it wasn't
because i was excited that wow
finally i've been asking for x-men
legends game for you i don't care what
platform it would be
but i will say i was kind of mad that
ultimate alliance came out on the switch
i'm still furious oh i'm with you bro
why i'm with you i want the petition i
want them to come at the detention.org